our first big political event was called
the wingding in iowa
um it was in clear lake iowa
um this is a famous democratic political
event um
and this was two oh yeah 2018 so like
off year
it was us who knew but nobody knew um
john delaney
tim ryan and michael avenatti and
michael avenatti who is
um a famous race car driver very
successful his own right became a lawyer
and was stormy daniels
lawyer and stormy daniels is the porn
star who accused donald trump of a
number of things
um and there was all this hype around
michael avenatti
all this hype michael now he's gonna be
trump he's a bully yang yang did a good
job like
i can't say a great job i can't say
brought the house down because
i eventually saw him two years later
bring down the house at certain moments
um and so like comparatively not as
great but it was an early speech for him
it was solid and it was
definitely insightful interesting he got
us polite iowa standing o
but people listened for sure um
he was one of the better speakers of the
night for sure michael avenatti gets up
there everybody's supposed to be five
minutes delaney tim ryan we're five
minutes
um avenatti goes for like 15 read from a
script
and was horrid like horrific i wish i
think you could find this on youtube
it's so
boring and so dry
like didn't get the standing out like
nobody cared
um this guy was like any objective
person in that room is like this guy
isn't gonna be
president like he's like a horrific
public speaker um the media swarmed him
after
and all every single headline out of
there avenatti
stars in the fires up the democrats and
i was like this is just
bs it's just a straight up lie and like
the but my point was that the
piece had been written before the event
right like they were ready like how
often probably when you're younger too
maybe or how often your colleagues like
told to go cover event but by the way
you're there for avenatti
like you're there for trump like what
how often because when things
when they when the narrative does change
in real time i don't think that gets
covered and that was frustrating for us
in many ways
throughout the race this is us this is
zach and i just trying to uh
understand what happened on the on the
campaign and all these things we lived
through
this is therapy for us this is this is
this you're just here to talk us down
we've been holding on for this for a
long time you know
so like avenatti is a great example
right of of here's this guy if you went
back and looked and i think that there
was a
there were a couple of uh of places that
did this that tallied his total number
of like cable news hits there for a few
months it was like
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
cable news hits right yeah for this guy
who's a complete fraud a complete a
complete charlotte he's in jail by the
way
and has dm me from jail i can't wait to
show you from jail
okay it's the same story so andrew in
2019 was i think it was during the yang
media blackout was basically [ __ ] on
whatever the media establishment and
saying i was there when michael avenatti
was not very good
and michael avenatti responded and this
was after he went to jail for
nike fraud whatever he did in that deal
um he's in jail
and he tweets like you suck blah blah
blah and i retweeted him
saying like is michael avenatti tweeting
from jail
and then he dm'd me and he's like he
like raged him do you didn't
you're a boss yeah you're like you're
bosses blah blah blah suck like you need
to spend more time he's pulling at one
percent you suck like it was just
like dude why you talking i was nobody i
was like
yeah well so this is so he's a he's a
great example of this right
um nobody thinks that michael
avenatti is a serious person uh
nobody thinks that michael avenatti is a
particularly
uh you know ethical or upstanding person
somebody who like really deserves to
have a soapbox in the public square
but michael avenatti knew how to get
ratings
michael avenatti was going to say a
bunch of crazy [ __ ] michael avenatti was
going to
uh be just as sort of flamboyant and
then
cindy and and as incendiary and um
kind of reckless rhetorically as trump
right and
so they're going to put him on the
airwaves uh and every reporter
who can get his number is going to text
him and try and get him in a story i
don't know that it's as prevalent as you
would think
that reporters are being sent to the
event saying hey
you know avenatti's going to speak be
ready
to write about him but i think that once
the event starts
uh for for a reporter in the room
who sort of uh has their own discretion
about what they're going to write
they want to get they want to get you
know clicks they want their
they want their story to gain traction
on social media
and if they just know from sort of the
buzz in the room
and from what other people are saying uh
before during and after the event
if they know that you know a headline
about michael avenatti
crashes the party and sets fire to trump
is going to get
more clicks than uh andrew yang uh
pitches uh a freedom dividend then
that's the story they're gonna write
nine times out of ten right like
here's a chicken in the egg question for
you guys right because i'm not trying to
um i'm not trying to dodge the bullet
here i think the media owns
some real culpability for this but
whether it's with the media
or with members of congress or with the
wall street collapse in 2008
like we can look at any of these
institutions and how they have failed
but how much of the blame belongs on the
consumer
right how like how much how much fault
lies
with the uh the the
wall street firm that was uh over
leveraging
individuals and and setting them up with
bad loans versus how much blame belongs
to the individual
who over leveraged themselves and took
out a mortgage that they knew that they
couldn't afford well i would challenge
that though
is that is totally accurate until you
guys choose
not to cover not to cover it right i
think you know what i'm saying like
the one thing we focused was like we
know that andrew yang is catnip
to me like when you do have these
dynamics right where you have bad
behavior on say the part of wall street
and you maybe
have uh there's a mix of culpability
between the consumer
and the the market actor that's to me
where you have kind of government to
step in or you have some sort of
regulation
i know very little about regulation in
like the journalism space
is there a place in your opinion for
regulation in this or
or no that just gets into really risky
territory well yeah look i mean the
first amendment is
as unequivocal as as it gets as far as
you know
uh what constraints we have in in the
press
but that doesn't mean so just because
we're free from any sort of official
regulation doesn't mean we're free from
uh accountability and and um and
you know listen the
the accountability needs to come from
within that's that's
the first line of defense right is great
editors great newsroom leaders
who can help uh to make the editorial
process
as rigorous and transparent and
accountable
as as as humanly possible right and then
i think that there's sort of a secondary
uh layer of of self correction
self accountability uh from uh from
from within the media more broadly so
from outside of your individual newsroom
there are media reporters and media
ombudsmen
and people who are whose job it is from
within their own perch in the media to
hold media accountable
right and that's a really important
function that we should be playing and
that i think we don't really do well
enough frankly
and then i think to my point a minute
ago guys about the individual
responsibility versus the institutional
responsibility
um i think really the the the market
at a certain point has to speak for
itself readers
should be uh providing the sort of
accountability and viewers
should be providing the sort of
accountability uh that
dictates what we are producing right
so they shouldn't be booking michael
avenatti on cnn
you know 30 times in in 15 days right
but why are
they right because clearly their their
internal
data algorithms are showing them that
that traffic is spiking
and that people are tuning in and so
and and to me that's where there's a
real question about
sort of consumer habits and how do we uh
both as members of the media and as
consumers of news
like how do we help to fix this right
and like i'm just speaking for myself
i really try to reward
good journalism i try and spend my time
engaging
with journalism that's done right and
frankly i'm going to piss off some of my
friends by saying this but like
i don't watch cable news it's for the
most part i find it to be poison
and and what you put into your body is
important and what you put into your
mind is important
and if you want to watch out man yeah
like if you want to watch um
you know i i have people ask me all the
time like friends family members like
well then where do you like if you're
watching tv
i said look if you if you need to get
your news from tv
watch your local nightly newscast on the
you know cbs affiliate or the fox
affiliate or whatever
or watch the pbs newshour with judy
woodruff and just get the facts
and then shut it off like you don't need
to stay up late into the night watching
cable news because
it's not really giving you much uh by
way of
useful objective journalism it's just
not
[Music]
you